here's Barrett Randall underneath oh
look out and that hurts Anthony Davis
took it right on the tailbone in the
back
Wow here's the introduction I like he
had many before but Anthony Davis meet
mr. flora that smarts
you got a timeout hopefully when we come
back Anthony will be up on his feet it
able to continue with 245 to go here in
the third reluctant to move ad for the
moment he is still down in the entire
team around him mean attended to by the
training staff if you're squeamish about
these things you can turn away now we're
going to show it again and you'll be
able to hear it also as ad gets helped
up
noticin they would take him straight to
the locker room and hopefully he won't
have to return to the game they can
evaluate and treat
walking under his own power there that
you see a little gym penis join them you
can understand why I've here it is again
just a violent collision with the floor
for Anthony Davis one up trying to make
a play on Julius
it's her but he's heart stopped for just
a moment holding their breath Anthony
Davis superstar that the violation
otherwise it would have been all the way
down to the other end yeah he's not
coming back maybe they were thinking are
we gonna put him up on the gurney there